hey guys it is the 30th of April today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but news the sub Dead
Island 2 has been delayed from 2015 to
sometime next year develop a deep Silva
have delivered the same spiel every dev
does when they need to push their game
which is that they want more time to
make a better product specifically this
means they're hoping to fully realize
the games co-op content and combat
options so as to not disappoint their
fans dead island has been something of a
popular franchise lately with a movie
and a MOBA also in the works unlike its
predecessor Dead Island 2 is being
produced by Yeager the dev behind spec
ops the line and not polished studio
Techland and news that is both old and
new the ps4 is selling pretty well
Sony's game division has recorded 404
million dollars worth of operating
profit in the past 12 months this pretty
big number was due in large part to the
success of the ps4 which sold 14.8
million units in the last year the
publisher are expecting to sell another
16 million units in their next twelve
month period from April 2015 onward
unless awesome news the PlayStation Vita
and PlayStation TV haven't been doing so
well as the company's portable division
have reported sales of 3.3 million down
from 4.1 million in the previous year
all up the company's yearly earnings are
at a seven-year high up 159 percent
year-on-year finally PC gamers have
something to be excited about today as
yet another e3 conference has been
announced this time focusing solely on
PC games sure we're already getting
conferences from microsoft sony nintendo
you ve a Bethesda and Square Enix up for
PC gamers this could be just the thing
you're after the so-called PC gaming
show is set to be held on Tuesday jun 16
at five p.m. PDT it's being put on by PC
gamer magazine and sponsored by AMD
don't worry if you won't be in LA at the
time though
the whole thing will be live streamed on
twitch in news i'm personally super
excited about the show is being hosted
by a sports figure and live stream ER
shun day 9 Plott among the confirmed
attendees are dayz creator dean hall
cliff bleszinski blizzard square enix
and obsidian let me know down in the
comments which III press conference
you're most excited about and why you
can add to gamespot we've got stories on
watch dogs too and the microsoft
hololens coming to e3 that's everything
i wanted to tell you about today do you
remember that tomorrow I'll have the top
5 best stories of the whole gaming week
ready to go so check back with me then